esfuerzos de rescate y ayuda
humanitarias en esos ejes se centra la
situación en Turquía y Siria
respectivamente en las regiones turcas
los grupos de rescatistas continúan
trabajando contra reloj para desenterrar
a los civiles sin embargo junto con la
cifra de muertos también crece pesimismo
y sacar a las personas de los escombros
ya no es garantía de supervivencia
El problema es que después de una
operación de rescate tan complicada el
riesgo para los pacientes es
particularmente alto Durante las
próximas 48 horas y es por eso que los
médicos sabían que solo después de 48
horas realmente se puede saber si un
paciente puede sobrevivir a algo así en
Siria las primeras ayudas humanitarias
internacionales arribaron a las zonas
controladas por Rebeldes los Países
Árabes de la región también enviaron
toneladas de apoyo para los civiles
afectados inclusive un convoy de 12
camiones aquí mientras una campaña de
donativos del Cairo prepara otra docena
de vehículos y tres aviones
estoy aquí ayudando con las colectas que
vamos a enviar a Siria para las víctimas
del terremoto uno de mis amigos se puso
en contacto con esta organización ayuda
a reunir muchas donaciones que
entregamos y ahora todos estamos aquí
ayudando a empacar y etiquetar las cajas
que se colocarán en un vuelo para ir a
Siria
se espera que en las próximas horas la
cantidad de muertes siga aumentando en
el terremoto que según el jefe de ayuda
de Naciones Unidas Martin griffith es el
más grave de la región en los últimos
100 años